we will continue taking call 617 830 for
750 is the number we like to take calls
once a week right now maybe maybe it'll
go up if there's demand for it I think
we have our next caller uh Louis doing
not yet we don't ok not yet um yeah so
the the reaction to the calls really has
been quite positive we've had a couple
duds so far but for the most part the
calls have been good and my instinct is
that this next caller that's joining me
now is going to be one of the best
callers yet who who's on the phone with
me now uh hi David to Derek god I got a
question for you ok so you know a lot of
the right likes to say that Trump is
like this anti politically correct
Crusader or whatever yeah yeah well did
you know that he sued bill maher for
making fun of them I've never eating
anything about the story how long ago
was that I think it was when he was
getting brought up on the birth of
things so Bill Maher said that he Donald
Trump has to prove that he is in the
product of his mother uh pleasuring
orangutang or whatever yeah yeah I
really quite knowing what you're gonna
pick on in other words what's what's our
take on Trump on the one hand saying
that he is the anti political
correctness guy but then he went after
Bill Maher uh because you're saying
because he just didn't like the tone or
tenor was offended by something Bayer
Bill Maher said in other words it's a
double standard you're pointing out and
also don't also the onion and he sends
letters to people say his hands are too
small yeah I mean that he says he'll
actually proactively as president make
it easier to sue media outlets who
publish negative stuff I think that I
think two things number one this is
completely authoritarian right the the
idea of making it easier to sue the
press that it's a completely
authoritarian strong handed move it it's
the likes of what we see in both
right-wing and left-wing dictatorships
lack of freedom of the press and
government intervention free press
etcetera that's number one the bigger
question though they are getting to is a
good one which is Donald Trump seems to
do a lot of the opposite of what he
as so it's a it's a lot of do as I say
not as I do and this applies to so many
areas of of his campaign and you're
pointing out one of them so yeah I mean
it's a total hypocritical double
standard but it surprises me absolutely
not at all yes I know you guys a long
ago I just wanted to say really quick
that I've been listening for close to
four years and I'm gonna really miss
Lewis so peace out dude oh well thank
you that's nice to hear the lowest
farewell tour is in full effect and you
are the first guest on that uh farewell
tour thank you so much for the call i
appreciate it yeah apology alright uh
very nice color louis uh very very
friendly guy very nice here